estamos de regreso para actualizar la
información económica en france 24 y por
eso está en nuestros estudios por
supuesto nuestro compañero luis méndez
zúrich louis vamos a comenzar hablando
de un sector que va en expansión
especialmente en américa latina como un
nuevo motor no para lo que son las
economías de la región estamos hablando
de la industria del cannabis así es
santiago varios países ya están
impulsando esta industria como bien lo
apuntas se está consolidando y va
proyectando un crecimiento importante
dentro de varios países de la región
pero ello ha ido de la mano de marcos
regulatorios claves para llevarlos a
cabo lo primero que se debe tomar en
cuenta es que la región más allá de
contar con un territorio fértil para la
producción de esta planta también es un
área donde existe interés en desarrollar
emprendimientos pero dejando de lado un
debate interno sobre hacia qué lado
apuntarse al thc que es la molécula
psicoactiva del cannabis o al cb de el
derivado de la planta con beneficios
para la salud muchos coinciden en que
américa latina' con este producto 9 en
el error de trabajarlo como otros
elementos o materias primas es decir que
no sea un commodity que se exporta para
luego comprar productos terminados sino
que se trabaje para agregarle valor y
poner en marcha toda una industria
orientada a la explotación de esta
planta pero para entender más sobre el
impacto que esta planta está teniendo en
la sociedad de américa latina' en france
24 conversamos con marco algorta ex
presidente de la cámara de empresas de
cannabis medicinal y esto fue lo que nos
dio el impacto que puede tener en la
latinoamérica atómica realmente se
desconoce a ciencia cierta los números
hablan de enormes proyecciones hablan de
varios millones de dólares pero yo creo
que latinoamérica tiene que empezar a
concentrarse en general los primeros
pasos claros hoy en día lo que vemos hay
muchísimas empresas un enorme sector que
se viene desarrollando muchas
inversiones que se vienen haciendo y
creo que debemos trabajando paso a paso
para consolidar esta industria y no
preocuparnos tanto en generar un impacto
enorme pero sí en construir algo
sostenible
económicamente como ecológicamente
ahora louis una pregunta que surge no en
este contexto es a nivel económico es
cuán grande es el mercado de cannabis en
el mundo y en particular en américa
latina' ya lo vamos a revisar pero
primero declaró que es un mercado en
expansión y de acuerdo con el global
cannabis reports en el año 2020 el uso
médico legal generó ventas por el orden
de los 10 mil 200 millones de dólares el
uso adulto tuvo un valor de 13 mil 400
millones de dólares la proyección de
acuerdo con este reporte es que para el
año 2025 en conjunto el mercado tenga
ventas por encima de los 51 mil millones
de dólares pero como lo hemos indicado
anteriormente todo esto está de la mano
de las regulaciones que en esta materia
puedan desarrollar los países
actualmente los países de américa que
cuentan con regulaciones sobre el
cannabis está canadá de eeuu en algunos
estados méxico y uruguay con fines
recreativos con fines medicinales
argentina chile colombia ecuador jamaica
paraguay y perú pero veamos en qué
sectores se deben orientar las
inversiones en esta área en américa
latina'
bueno obviamente que ha empezado todo
esto por el lado medicinal y un poco las
empresas se han posicionado de en ese
sector pero también hay que entender que
latinoamérica no tiene una enorme
tradición en producir medicamentos o
productos y elementos medicinales
entonces está bien latinoamérica tiene
entender que por ejemplo en sus o
veterinarios donde si tenemos una larga
producción de producción los usos
alimenticios de los cannabinoides esos
deben ser los sectores donde debemos
profundizar porque donde tenemos las
cadenas productivas ya establecidas para
otros sectores y rápidamente la podemos
reconvertir para la industria de
cannabis entonces y obviamente el
alimento no solo el cb de la semilla el
calle moco alimento también nosotros de
lo que tenemos trabajar a fondo
otra pregunta louis surgen muchísimas
preguntas y dudas sobre este tema hacia
donde apunta el crecimiento de la
industria por supuesto que el
crecimiento de la industria tiene un
impacto significativo y lo primero que
tenemos que tomar en cuenta es que por
lo menos en uruguay hasta agosto del año
2020 esta industria había generado
ingresos por el orden de los 8 millones
de dólares en colombia donde también
están avanzando a pasos agigantados para
consolidar esta industria ha tenido una
proyección de 245 millones de dólares
para el próximo año por su parte en
méxico la valoración de este mercado
está por el orden de los 3 mil 200
millones de dólares para los próximos
años bueno les muchísimas gracias por
esta interesantísima crónica de todo
este nuevo motor para muchísimas
economías que es el cannabis a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación sigan con nosotros
y